what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alban
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch a
music video that I am so excited to
check out it's from slash Street Boys as
long as your bloody Backstreet Boys
parody this is a topper war to your
video requests from man named Lance door
that handsome Canadian firefighting
engaged son of a B and he actually
introduces the slash three boys last
year this is great timing I remember
these guys even commented in our video
saying don't react to our next one they
like that reaction before so I'm excited
to check this out over at our patreon we
do weekly q and A's TV show reaction
stream along as many shows have reaction
highlights included he does music video
coverage at least three times a week
wanted to shout that out let's watch
this
[Music]
kill board
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I hope them funny
oh it does work really well long as
you're bloody I must have been wearing
what you did huh oh hello there Chris
[Music]
good match cuts his face Val tip
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how they shot it like a eighties music
like Ghazi
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I love these guys hey no
it's ready gonna get a verse
[Music]
maybe's him and Leatherface in the
chorus
[Music]
Hey
Brett Freddie looks the best
I mean like pretty I can watch just kind
of looks like Freddie yeah good mask
[Music]
go Steve
it's
obviously the child is unlike a dvcam
but this was a real Bluebird
Americans did it again merkins did it
again oh boy Jason
shout as if we know one of them Oh Matt
all right
they had stunt opens one of them looking
special thanks the Backstreet Boys don't
forget making such an awesome song yeah
Beno parody without it go check out
their patreon guys and subscribe to them
as soon as you can dump money on them
well this was great what it's cool about
it I would be I'll kill you that way
which is the one we watched last year
that was like an a Backstreet Boys music
video they even had like the white
outfits on on the beach and everything
close yeah and then here it looks like
an 80s music and I know that those faces
from the 90s not the 80s but everyone
else pretty much originated seventies
eighties time having that aesthetically
you pointed out look there was shot on a
DVR it looks like her the way they
edited added some sort of kind of grain
to it and then even the high school look
yeah they really go to a real high
school it looks like a real like a
science lab or something they were
always with locker rooms and stuff
lockers it felt like they probably
rented out a real high school or maybe
one of them is like a custodian or
something and again there let's shoot
this little YouTube it's crazy how
flawless their parody rhymes it works so
well fits really nicely for two
Backstreet Boys songs in a row on a road
and a lot of other things in between
since last year replace love with murder
as long as you love me as long as you're
bloody and like that just it's perf
syllable so you know it's perfect I bet
that's probably how they came up with it
I bet they start yeah with the titles is
like what kind of pun can we make an in
into yeah like a slasher take on one of
these song and then the rest just
probably writes itself they are building
sort of an actual boy band out of this
you have Jason
Ghostface and Michael taking the sort of
lead vocals and you have Freddy and
Leatherface in the background doing the
chorus and stuff like that and I even
bother to have Leatherface change masks
to do the pretty lady and like the
you know more just regular skin mask
yeah I love the reoccurring bit of how
they're they're dumping these bodies but
they're not actually going down
that's how really go right yeah yeah
yeah we would float to somebody to put
rocks on them yeah if you guys need
advice on how to get rid of a body in
the water you got to make sure to put at
least some weight on it some rocks or
something like that
fill the corpse with stones any
subscribers listening all right this is
when people tweet at us going oh the you
know it's not movies and video games
that are inspiring you know bad people
in the world
it's influencers people with YouTube
channels who make sarcastic jokes but
this is not a joke really if you want a
body to go underwater that's dead you
got it put some rocks on it yeah I mean
that's the other the kinds of comments
we get is like this body isn't sinking
what gives guys you told me what to do I
did it you know DM me and I'll help you
figure it out yeah keep it all the
comments yeah I don't want that going
public DM private and sensing news I was
a little bummed though that uh you know
there's only so many verses they can
have six verses and I was a little
bummed that if Freddie didn't get to
have his own verse I know
neither did Leatherface I think for
parodying as long as you love me it
works well because you got Ghostface who
has his obsession with Sydney Sydney
michael has a session with Lauri Jason's
got his mom Jason Scott is because
sweaters exactly Tamela the men who are
super associated with the women then
allow their face and Freddy they don't
really have that which is a bummer
that's to be the reboot well there you
go
Leatherface finds love and so does
Freddie and then you know they haunt
each others worlds Freddie not versus
Leatherface but Freddie and Leatherface
need dates well in the day and age we
live in when they reboot them lord knows
Leatherface is gonna be a woman now no
yeah so is Freddie yeah gonna be played
by Tiffany Haddish
that's right that's right yeah yeah and
then how come no dream i /e whoa yeah
and she's not even gonna have the makeup
on it's gonna be Tiffany had as just
doing her thing like improving you know
everyone else gonna act around and
rebel Wilson his Leatherface mm-hmm yeah
and she's just gonna come in football
fan or you know fall through a butcher
table fall through the woods and you
know land the chainsaw on someone by
accident and then try to seduce someone
and it's funny because she's she's gonna
fall in a second due to her weight yeah
she's like not subtle with her sexiness
so it's like awkward haha funny Jesus it
kind of reboots that we're hoping for
again this is how we get tweeted at
right here first sarcastic comments but
these are not sarcastic comments no we
don't do that I'd rather have Melissa
McCarthy in the role Leatherface mm-hmm
cuz very different kind of comedy as
opposed to but seriously it seemed like
they throw down a budget for this they
even got a speed I got a speed like I
don't know where these guys are based at
but even still like to go out on a lake
seems like you'd have to either have
that boat which seems like they borrowed
that boat is very least I mean they got
like footage or they're like some
dumpster yard of like car parts yeah
like a junkyard is just some persons oh
yeah I'm not sure where they shot this
or rather located you feel that kind of
Midwest area that's like you where you
can just go outside and find a location
and just shoot in it and no one will
probably bother you in all seriousness
this was great I hope one day that they
can get picked up to do their own
feature-length movie and then it's
ruined
by trying to make what works as a sketch
parody group into a full-length movie
and people go too much it was annoying
they should have just stuck to sketches
no but when that day comes I'm excited a
two-hour movie slam is Rob perfect what
happened to your yes ands always I mean
it would suck no come on eat movie I
know a zoo but word we didn't get you a
tattoo if there's no but but what about
pop star never stop never never always
slash always slash it Mont monster I
don't I'm trying hard and then they can
send out merkins emblazoned with their
logo as press gifts the more you talk
the better it gets
that's the policy
alright guys well make sure to subscribe
to merkins by yourself American
subscribe to the real rejects you can
click our notification about to get
notified whenever forgot a youtube video
up you can check us on patreon where we
got a bunch of mumbo jumbo
Lance door thank you so much again buddy
congratulations on your anniversary with
your fiance Halloween is actually the
day of their anniversary so you know
what that means you guys got to get some
sexy costumes sexy costumes I'm talking
you get yourself like a freddy masks and
you get the hands and the the scissor
hands and then you dress her up as Nancy
come Oh Jason no leather come prawn no
but nobody going Oh shite yes you're
gonna be other characters let's get
Pennywise in here let's expand the
universe it's hi
you should bring in the first female to
the group make this like the Black Eyed
Peas
yeah I know cuz we're sorry has his cost
I'm telling it to the audience because I
don't know they don't know well oh I see
I get I get what you mean this shout
outs going great uh you have just like
you know you're doing where you named
random supporting actors and no one
knows who they are and you just expect
us to know and then you wait for us to
go whoo I've stopped doing that now I
just say the thing if I I don't drop
things and it's a good weight for a what
is that yes but Lance blender water bone
your soon-to-be wife and some creepy
costumes with your kid watching there